i think it's very important that
everybody in uh politics listens first
to the
the clinicians and to the medical
experts and i would
i would just urge all uh families uh
thinking about this across the country
to listen to the jc
vi uh the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
uh they are extremely expert they're
they're amongst the best if not the best
in the world they know uh what's what's
safe and i think we should listen
and listen to them and and take our lead
from them are expecting an update on the
travel list soon there'll be a lot of
good news to people
um do you think we're expecting any
holidays to france and spain to be
opened up for brits lots of people will
be wondering this
nora you don't have to wait long i i've
said before
i think uh a couple of days ago that i
know
how important holidays are to
people people think about them they save
up for them
people yearn to go abroad this year
totally i totally get that we've got to
balance that
against the need to protect our country
against the influx of
of new variants uh we've got a a
balanced policy but
clearly we have the benefit now of the
double
jab system that is enabling us to
uh to to go to uh countries in the eu
and to come back to countries
come from from the countries in the u
without having to uh to quarantine and
same for same goes for the u.s